it's important to understand the
struggle because the truth is we're
always in the struggle Cincinnati in the
90s it's a hell of a decade its
obscenity in the 90s very foundations of
our society are endangered
[Music]
no sexuality incompatible with military
service
[Music]
he said I am a dream today
about the sons of former slaves and the
sons of
slave owners he made no distinction
between the straight ones and the gay
ones
[Music]
what was the impact as you start to you
know find out about sexual orientation
protections in 1992 because it it wasn't
something that was done with fanfare you
know tell each other the truth here
though I mean really you want to talk
truth they were guide to a very powerful
and Proctor and only got more powerful
who didn't want to give equal right to
the LGBTQ community we didn't deserve it
[Music]
so moving to Cincinnati was a challenge
for me I really wanted to help a city
like Cincinnati change cuz if I could
help Cincinnati become more LGBTQ
friendly that can spread I wanted to
make that change I was dedicated to
making that change in the world
so Cincinnati was my battleground
a PNG sexual orientation was added to
the EEO policy toward the end of 92 it
was a big thing for P&G at the time
given its conservative nature it was a
big day I read it and couldn't believe
it I honestly couldn't believe my eyes I
think I walked out a second time to
reread it to make sure it was real
there's beginning to be that feeling of
we're gonna be free and boy how wrong we
were so it's not like boom you've got
this anti-discrimination thing and now
it's going to be you know Bambi at the
still Blue Lake it just doesn't work
that way PNG almost did that they almost
put sexual orientation in the policy as
a bit of a legal thing that's exactly
right
it wasn't like they were planning to do
anything different once they got the
words in there was no program or policy
that I can remember that that went with
it not the initial perception was that
it was a win yeah it was not it provided
recognition to employees that we existed
it actually got worse during that time
when I would walk into the ladies
restroom most of the people to walk out
if I sat down at at eight one of the
long lunch tables they would get up and
leave and then at the same time in
Cincinnati you get this referendum that
passed putting in the so-called article
12 in the city's Constitution article 12
issue 3 represents discrimination and
we're not going to tolerate
discrimination in our community
article 12 prevented protection for gay
people in employment and housing within
the city of Cincinnati specifically
excluded gay people as a protected class
it seems like you're making it up
because it's so crazy it said that city
council was disallowed from messing any
legislation that would protect gay
people from discrimination now that's
not how it was on the ballot the people
that put it on the ballot control the
language they would have this laundry
list of hot-button terms she can't
create special rights for gay people you
can't create quotas really having a
house as special rights having a job and
not feel like they could just walk in
and say we really don't like you I
actually wants us asked to describe to a
group of PNG women from around the world
what it's like to be gay what the
experience is late and the way I
described it was it is to never know
when you're going to be hunted and
therefore you always have to be prepared
that this is the day that somebody
decided that your well-being is a threat
to their happiness not only did article
12 pass but 2/3 of the voters in
Cincinnati voted for it I remember
walking through the halls of PNG and
thinking the majority of you voted for
this you went out of your way to make
sure that I don't feel secure in my job
or my housing I don't know that I was
ever as mad again as I was the day after
article 12 passed and I walked in and
said I'm going to make change happen in
the halls and walls of my employer I
started looking for my community for
LGBTQ people in PNG who I could relate
to and I ended up finding the potlucks
enough of us had kind of chatted and
said hey you know if this is something
that's recognized by PNG it's in our
Equal Employment Opportunity policy we
should feel free to associate as a group
of gay and lesbian employees
what happened with me as I was playing
in a volleyball league that happened to
have Gery right in it and he said sort
of noticed that you're blatantly out do
you have any interest in being a part of
this group and I'm like absolutely I
mean it really was part of my journey
even before PNG and that I wanted to
continue of actively working to to
create the world I want to live in I had
just moved back to Cincinnati with the
family and it was difficult so I've
wanted to have the chance to make a
difference
part of what Gary brought was he could
talk his way around a lot of things he
was very comfortable with leadership he
was really good at that subtle stuff
that was one of his superpowers so five
of us came together to talk about what
we wanted from the company that was the
start of everything was those meetings
during that time article twelve
emboldened even more name-calling and
threats like you know that posturing I
remember walking with our director with
a PNG and we had passed a newspaper
stand and there was a headline about
gays wanting to like petitioning to
parade or something like that and he
said oh my god those people should all
just go to an island if you're in the
closet you can't be bringing all your
energy to the workplace because you're
holding some of that energy to protect
your own identity your own sense of
safety I think so the five of us got
together there was discussion around the
interest of saying hey you know this is
great to have this PEO policy but there
are actions in the workplace that we
need to address and there are further
things that can be done in deploying
policy first we need an identity I mean
we work in a branding company let's get
serious I started just playing around
with logos and names so that we could
come up with some way to refer to us
that wasn't necessarily like flashing
red lights the gay group so we started
calling at cable sort of the idea of the
gable of a house being roof and
protection and a gathering place over
the people so it had a little bit of me
in forest as a word in a name the
letters reflected who we wanted to be
tables be informed in the mid-nineties
was a big deal even for someone like me
I felt maybe I'm not totally alone
anymore
there's a number of what the company was
beginning to call diversity groups you
know women managers or african-americans
affinity groups at Procter & Gamble
typically had an eye on conference and
it stands for interoffice Network so
that they could communicate among one
another so there was a normal process
for requesting anion conference for a
group so I just filled out the form and
submitted it and we got our iron group
the ion conference was really a way of
saying we would be officially recognized
we had it all going we were we were
cooking with gas and then just got cut
off this is an inappropriate use of
company resources based on what I mean
the the fine thing was there was no
process that existed they had to create
it to say no to us basically but that's
how it got to be the significance that
it was it wasn't that to begin with it
was just an ion conference everybody was
part of like 18 ion conferences but I
mean that's really what led us to like
standing up and saying we want a forum
on these tasks for three things yeah
the three requests were that first we
wanted gay and lesbian issues included
in diversity training the second one was
the ion conference and then the third
one was domestic partner benefits
domestic partner benefits was always the
the core that held us together it was a
universal importance to us so what we
decided was we we'd start at the very
top of the company we wanted to go to
the top HR person we sent him a letter
and requested a meeting with him to talk
about what we wanted he sent us back a
note basically saying I don't meet with
groups like yours I have my direct
reports do that come on now
break what we realized was that he had
just given us permission to approach
every single one of his direct reports
and say your boss said we're supposed to
meet with you so we wrote Lavelle bond
and said we're a group of PG employees
we are lesbian gay and bisexual and we'd
like to meet with you to talk about that
he wrote back to us and said you can
meet with my associate VP Waldo Jeff I
wasn't in that organization a week
before I received a call from Heidi
bruins I don't even know where the
bathroom is in this organization yet and
you already called me to begin the
battle in the global world with sexual
orientation a wall that was there and he
was writing an agenda on the whiteboard
and his hand was shaking he was so
nervous I really didn't know what to
expect he might have been scared of us
that first meeting but he listened and
that was really evident in who he was if
you're being discriminated against I
have learned you have to fight back I
was born in segregated Moyles I have
seen exclusion and discrimination and
very early age if gays and lesbians at
TNT are willing to stay enough for
themselves and fight for their rights I
sure know what it's like to do that when
this young lady Heidi Bruins got in my
ear and said well do you know nobody
else is going to advocate for us but you
I knew that she was right a PNG the
whole idea is that you're sharing data
we're all about the data we did the
research found out what other companies
were doing understood the tax
implications and the costs that they had
incurred we would have these binders
that would have a lot of information the
kinds of questions that people ask you
know how much is this gonna cost
who does this affect why should we do
this where is the justification for it
just to help people to make their
decisions in our favor to side with us
was the idea it was pretty much a
resistance initially one time one of the
vice presidents came into my office and
shut the door and told me that he was
concerned that I was beginning to create
an environment in the company that was
immoral and he would never support and
that my working with top management on
that had to cease or he personally was
going to see to it that I was terminated
what that incident taught me was how we
use power to bully one of the objections
that we heard is that you're you're
telling us about these things that
happen in these far-off places they
don't happen in Cincinnati and they
don't happen at P&G but because of
article 12 they actually did so we
started collecting people's stories I
was so scared that the powers that be at
P&G would find out I was gay that for
like seven years in addition to lying by
omission about my lifestyle I actually
manufactured a wedding and a husband
that of course resulted in a very
tangled web of lies but my energy was
totally focused on maintaining the lives
I had ulcers paranoia and a total loss
of self-esteem one time they were in the
throes of doing some mandatory training
and there was a manager and he said if I
ever see any gay people I'm just gonna
kill him I had had an international
assignment I'd lived for three years in
Manila and the Philippines and my
partner was there with me we had to
figure out how to have him be there
living with me there was no official
accommodation for a partner at that
point in time I mean this was incredibly
difficult I was pretty proud of my
family my three sons and the life we had
built together I never felt like my
company recognized my family
that was the emotional toll financially
it was oppressive because I couldn't get
insurance for two of the three children
and my partner we had to purchase
insurance outside and that was extremely
expensive probably fifty five thousand
dollars just in medical care for my
family and so what we did is we sent two
people to meet with every single HR
leader and whenever they met with us
they're like oh you're like normal
people you look just like us and then
we'd share our stories and that was the
big thing that made a difference for so
many people you know it was the
difference between people like I'm
agreeing with this thing over here or
I'm disagreeing with this thing over
here and it would bring it into I am
looking at a real person so this is
where we've linked to Charlotte Auto and
public relations so that you could look
at it and say okay can the company
manage the external communication of
this without getting beat up I think
sharing his personal stories really took
it from the intellectual this is right
for the business to this is right for
our people because we care about every
individual because I got a personal
understanding that took me from observer
to advocate
her role wasn't to say we should go do
this her role was to say I can manage
this here was the person in charge of
the function that was responsible for
making sure that the external
communication wouldn't blow up in the
company's face and we can manage this
and at that point we have been working
on us for many many years it was a very
long process over the course of five
years we had prepared the environment to
be able to accept another level of
thinking and at that point we felt that
we were pretty much ready to move
forward so we got the company to vote on
same-sex benefits it was an overwhelming
vote of the aspirin and unfortunately
the vote was not implemented the answer
came back a very disappointing we won't
be leaders we will continue to benchmark
and we will do this mid-pack that was
the exact language used with this mid
path we felt defeated it became apparent
that through the grapevine that they
were going to be offering insurance for
pets and I thought I was gonna die
there's no way my company can make a
mistake like that to cover pets and not
cover children
[Music]
back then I was the one senior manager
foods now so there were people who did a
lot more for gay right the tractor who
really worked it worked so hard and I
can't say that I did I just was trying
to stay alive most of the time I wasn't
looking for people's approval I was just
looking for accepted all I wanted a
level playing field let me do good work
and judge me fairly I'll remember I got
a call from someone who at that time I
didn't know and his name was Gary right
and he came to my office as he said he
wanted to do or to talk about a subject
of diversity and he came and he had a
couple of folks with him who I can
hardly remember but I certainly remember
Gary he said John I know you're very
committed to diversity that's obvious to
us all but you need to know that there
is a huge outage in the way you're
approaching diversity in this company
well that got my attention and what he
said he was talking about was that we
were not recognizing a different way of
life in front of employees
now Susan Arnold was a very important
person to me
with the company Susan and I have worked
together in different parts of the soap
business for years and I never really
thought about her marital or personal
life one way or the other and I really
hadn't sat down with her and had a kind
of conversation that who are you what is
but your whole life like well there was
a one of these dividend days and I saw
Susan across the way and she was sitting
there with two young children and their
partner it came together for me in a
particular way because I knew Susan in
so many different dimensions but I
hadn't seen this it was the importance
of recognizing a person's full life and
the importance of their having a choice
on what that life would be
AG Lafley called and he said Billy Susan
I promise you that we are going to get
domestic partner benefit for P&G and for
me diversity is a business strategy it's
not just about doing the right thing
it's about doing right things right and
it's about building our business and our
organization for the long term at that
point having a company like P&G make a
bold statement like that was incredibly
powerful when Procter & Gamble's did it
it said something it spoke volumes it
rich company boycott it with product
boycott it wasn't it just wasn't that
they did it right they did it right and
they did it in the face of opposition
focused on the family decided to declare
a nationwide boycott of our products and
we had to go to the board because it did
impact our business and they were
supporting I mean they didn't just that
we back down at all we may not have been
first to the party but we I think threw
a pretty good party same-sex partner
benefits gave us the courage to step out
even more to take on article 12
but it's each of those steps that have
given us a stronger motivation and a
stronger voice to be a positive force of
change support for the repeal was the
point at which P&G became more public
about its commitment to equal treatment
for LGBT people it was the right thing
to do I don't know that anybody had a
master plan for let's do this slowly and
then this slowly and this slowly keep
that forward momentum but what I think
it says is there's a process we tend to
follow and we may not get somewhere
first but we'll get there better and
ultimately it sticks you look at the
dramatic change of the original EEO
policy you look at the public
announcement of the final domestic
partner benefits and you have the
support for the repeal of article 12
those three were big changes over a
fairly long period of time maybe over a
12-year period or so but
they were big changes each one of them I
think the thing that I'm proud of is if
people don't really want to think about
being gay if there's other things that
they are like a woman scientist or just
a woman in general who's like a strong
leader they get to focus on those things
that's really the win for me is that
people don't have to think about it if
they don't want to and they can focus on
the parts of themselves that they do
want to focus on here that gable is
5,000 members strong and in 54 countries
makes me want to cry
I think back when there were there were
just six of us I don't know that I ever
would have imagined a day like this
would come
we've looked just like you we talked
just like you and we are human just like
you really there's gay and lesbian
people all around you here this is my
Coulomb that I wrote for my retirement
as a youngster growing up in the bowels
of the deep south
I had the passion for equality and of
course this big big mount expected to be
treated equal equality had such huge
appeal
all I ever really wanted was a level
playing field those of you trying to
become the best that you can be use my
experience at TNG as one last gift from
me give more than you take perform with
passion and zeal demand excellence and
equality and a level playing field
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you